[Music]
let's go to suzanne in cleveland ohio
what's up suzanne
hi dr john hey big win for ohio
yesterday right
oh yeah you don't have any idea what i'm
talking about do you nope nope
you are awesome
dude the bengals won man
i'm really sad about that but um yeah
we're super dating the show
what'd you say james yeah yeah i was
just gonna say point out to people that
by the time this airs the super bowl oh
yeah by the time this show is over the
super bowl will be long over but
uh there's an ohio team never never it's
a game called football it's a whole mess
all right so what's up suzanne how can i
help
okay so this is a lot but bear with me
all right bring it on
uh my parents are in the middle of a
very messy divorce it's probably an
understatement
and my dad over the past year has been
making progressively worse and worse and
worse choices and
i'm just trying to figure out how to
handle all of it and
what my position is to like where to
step in um
yeah what a process so you use some very
eloquent distancing language i would
love what is what does messy divorce
mean
um
well
oh there's a lot
messy divorce like they can't like
they they won't they can't be in like
the same room together my parents and my
dad's refusing to find horse papers so
it's like he's just kind of getting
pushed along through all of this
what started all of this
what started all of it um
well
oh goodness a lot my dad growing up was
kind of abusive and
there's no such thing as kind of abusive
what kind of abusive was it
uh
verbally and
physically to my mom i would say okay
and financially yeah
very much so financially
what was that what was the inciting
incident that she just said enough's
enough
um
we found out that he there is some
infidelity on his part um
there is infidelity on her my mom's part
as well that's kind of what
started the whole like downfall of
everything and then he wanted to work
things out and then
yeah and then
it got the end was when it we found out
that it was him too
and your mom just said let's just call
it
uh my mom changed all the locks on the
door
so
so
you all grow up he's abusive he's
physically abusive he's verbally abusive
he plays power games with money
your mom
your mom
has eyes for somebody else has an affair
or two or three or four
and
he finds out and says
we should we should change let's figure
let's come back together
and then she says all right i'm in and
then she finds out he's been cheating on
her
and she says i mean
so we should like get back together that
was probably like six years and
of them trying to make things work and
but it was
a lot of counseling sessions and
nothing came out of it my dad was very
that's when the peak abusive stuff
happened i would for sure watch this tv
show by the way for sure
oh oh you haven't even gotten to like
the juicy part yet all right so way
better when you say he's making
increasingly worse choices what does
that mean
okay so
in
the last year
he um
like started partying pretty hard and
then um yes how old is he yeah
uh
65
it seems like a good time to start
partying sorry 50 56 56 or 58. somewhere
[Music]
okay so we just decided i'm gonna let
that
okay i'm start partying then what
happened yeah he started partying um and
then
last year he joined a motorcycle gang do
your dads and sons of anarchy
uh
yeah
uh
so yeah that's that's been a bit
frustrating um because i can't even have
like a conversation with him anymore
without that being all that's talked
about just his gang did he is he
so motorcycle gang it's got a
connotation to it but i knew some guys
that were in a um a great
great group is he looking for connection
and camaraderie or is he is he
yeah
definitely looking for connection and
camaraderie but they're
they're getting into some not so good
things okay all right okay
so
it's not influencing him in a good way
like we grew up in church and stuff and
there's like
i i just i just the what kicked off all
of this and my call to you is that i
just found out
about three weeks ago um that
he
um
pressured my little brother who is about
21 into doing mess with him
and
i'm wondering if it's a problem and i
was told this by my brother in complete
confidence what do you mean you're
wondering if this is a problem yeah no i
i get that it's very much okay good
more like a like an addiction problem
because he's also lost like a hundred
pounds in the last two months methyl did
that to you yes yeah yes so
what's your question i wasn't supposed
to tell anybody about this
and
my my dad has custody of my brothers on
the weekends and i'm not supposed to
tell my mom about this but then i did
tell her but now we all don't know what
to do because i don't want to ruin the
relationship between
me and my brother because
i told my mom
tell me about have to be confronted the
kids in the custody there's children
involved
yeah i have a 10 year old brother and a
15 year old brother
smokes yeah
so
this conversation
just took a a
significant turn
and yes a lot yeah so number one
i was poking some fun and all this i
know this is super hard for you before
we get into what we need to do have you
sat down and grieved this
this is shapeshifter for you
um
there's been a lot of crying i don't
know if i've fully grieved it it
definitely keeps me up at night yeah
exactly
um there's a couple of things i'm i'm
married out of the house with i just had
my first daughter uh
two months ago so like
like yeah it's definitely like just
overflowing into that relationship so i
don't know it's a lot big time yeah so
my guess is you're gonna have to spend
some time
whether it's with you in a notebook
writing some letters some imaginary
letters that you're never going to send
one of which is probably when you're a
little girl to your dad
like what was so bad about me as a
seven-year-old that you had to yell at
me like that
and how dare you hit mommy right
and yeah you need to
process that
you need to process when you found out
that mom had cheated on dad
and yeah like mom that's not how you
raised it like what happened like what
you know what i mean
and then you're gonna have to process
and grieve watching your dad literally
wither away in front of you
yeah
and then
this is a both and to this
you gotta grieve that hard stuff
and there's a whole that's a whole
process given what you grew up with
if you haven't spent time with a
counselor you probably should
um if you haven't ever sat down and told
your husband
some of the hard stuff you probably
should
uh yeah he's really supportive he knows
a lot of
he's probably too involved in all of it
as well well he loves you right and he's
not going to be that kind of guy you
probably married well to you didn't
repeat the cycle did you
no
it's awesome he's an awesome dad and
i love him we were yeah we're great so
what will happen is
as your daughter gets older your body
will begin remembering her trajectory
through this system
it will remember you at four and it'll
remember you at seven it'll remember you
at 14 when your dad said this or did
that or his buddy came over and looked
at you like this those things will begin
to come up as your daughter grows up
if they haven't already
and so
dealing with this trauma dealing with
this
grieving this is so important for you
for your relationship with your daughter
if your relationship with your husband
but
for you for you like i said it's keeping
you up at night and i want you to have a
night of sleep okay i want you to have
peace
so here's the both end so you gotta
grieve
what happened you gotta own what
happened and
you gotta deal with the tornado that's
sitting right on top of your house right
now
yeah if you know somebody's sharing meth
with with their child
with their 21 year old
then i'm gonna sit down with my younger
brother and say hey i need you to know
as the adult how old are you
24 yeah as the older sister i'm gonna
break your heart here i'm gonna make you
sad
and
i have to you have to know that i really
wrestled with this
i wrestled so hard i called some yahoo
on a podcast and asked what he didn't
mean
he needs to know that this wasn't easy
but that you have to throw a flag on
this
because you cannot in good conscience or
in
without violation of the law
send your brothers
back into this man's mess you can't yeah
and so what has to happen is it's gonna
be a mess it's gonna i mean
you gotta know you didn't create this
mess
you're getting in the middle of it to
help solve it because you're got two
children involved here
yeah
if this was just your 60 year old man
like
like just
man
just kind of spinning off into the
future here like i'm just gonna do drugs
enjoying a motorcycle gang and
like that's something to grieve there's
not a lot you can do about that
yeah what you can do and you must do is
get involved on behalf of these little
kids because no other adult is stepping
up for him
i hate hate hate that you have to be the
one to do this because you're a big
sister
but nobody else is i'm just trying to
figure out like
well i'm like my my mom is also like
trying to figure it like we're both in
it like trying to figure out how do i
like go about i don't i don't even know
how to begin this conversation my dad
doesn't
he likes to deny yeah there is no there
is no conversation here's how this is
gonna go down one you have a
conversation with your brother and you
say i can't keep my mouth shut about
this this is happening
number two you your mom not you but your
mom
files a custody request
with her attorney he said i've got
information that he used drugs using
meth with one of my other kids
and i'm no longer comfortable my kids
are no longer safe going to visit with
him and that should trigger some sort of
in the state of texas it was cps every
state's got different but child
protective services will get into an
investigation
and they will show up and potentially
drug test him they will potentially do a
house visit there's all kinds of things
that once that ball gets rolling
and all of that is i don't want a 10
year old in that environment
yeah and it's not even the motorcycle
stuff i don't have i don't have a
problem with it i don't know anything
about the gang but
i don't have a problem with that
inherently i have a problem with a dad
who's doing drugs with their kids
especially meth
for god's sake yeah i mean i don't like
know that he's doing that in front of
the younger kids and i would like to
hope that he has enough integrity not to
i mean he doesn't have the integrity to
do yeah
there you go
here's the thing
you and your mom
have been talking in circles for a long
long long long time
yeah
and somebody has to finally finally
finally be the adult
yeah and i hate that it's a falling on
you
because it should be dad and it should
be mom
yeah but somebody's got to do it and
your little brother your 21 year old he
he should know
he's gonna get in trouble and dad's
gonna call him a snitch there's gonna be
a whole bunch of thing and actually
what's gonna happen is he's gonna end up
denying it probably
he'll deny it or dad will deny it
there'll be a big he said she said or he
said he said whatever
and it'll cause drama and that's why you
gotta get the attorneys involved
yeah
or the court involved and they may do
nothing
wouldn't surprise me
but
you at least let dad know hey this kind
of behavior is not cool even if you go
as his daughter and write him a letter
and say you can't do this with my
brothers and sisters
and my brothers you can't can't do it
so like what if he just denies it
and
like how would i know if he's actually
honest about not doing it anymore has he
ever been honest with you before
no
has your brother ever lied to you
or that's that's a bad question
brother's a lifetime was he lying when
he told you
oh no most definitely not he felt
horrible he was almost crying telling me
about it there you go
so of course of course he's gonna deny
it there's no question about that yeah
yeah
so you're not doing an investigation to
see if this really happened what you're
doing is you're stepping in to protect
two children
yeah
and protecting means you're gonna call
the right people whether that's the
authorities whether that is
um
the courts whoever
and your mom's gonna be involved in that
and hopefully
hopefully
your mom steps in on behalf of those two
little kids
no she will okay i don't have doubt in
that yeah i think yeah we just both have
been so clueless on like i'm just scared
if we take what to be completely honest
i know that it's not fair for them to be
in the middle of it but i'm terrified of
what will
what my dad will do if he
loses custody of them just as far as i'm
alert already concerned about his will
to live
to be completely honest
so let me clear this up right now okay
if your dad hurts himself
that will not ever be on you
yeah
okay
yeah
do you believe me
um you don't and that's right i know
what you're saying it's okay
that's a great way to say that that's
that was
that was very eloquent suzanne
yes
um you know what i'm saying is true but
you don't believe me and i get that
totally get that
um
he's had a hard row and he's making some
not healthy good smart choices and it's
heartbreaking to watch someone you love
uh fall apart
even if you reach out and tell dad i
love you but you can't do math around my
brothers can't do it if they can't i
can't have them be over there
um let's try a custody for a year at
mom's and we don't even have to get the
courts involved
and
once you get yourself cleaned up and
he'll fight and say no but at least you
can look him in the eye and say i love
you or write him my letters he can read
it over and over and over and over again
yeah
and maybe you don't love him and i don't
want to put that on you maybe he's hurt
you and your mom and your family and now
your little brother so long
that you're done with that part
now it's just about i'm gonna protect my
family
is that where you are yeah
um no i i do really love him i actually
didn't have a relationship with him
except for in the last three years we
were able to
build a relationship and then
all of this started happening and it's
will they hear you
you don't know how to be roman
i
i don't know i i
doubt it honestly but
okay
i would try
so if you're safe if you feel safe yeah
maybe that's the
breakfast
the breakfast meeting that i love so
much and you have a handwritten letter
that you hand him at that at that
breakfast
can you say here it is i'm worried about
you you lost 100 pounds
it's clear that you're doing drugs i
can't have my brothers in this situation
i need you to know that i love you
um and i i
so want my dad back
and also
i've got to get in the middle and
protect my brothers
and so you can turn over custody for a
while you can let them come like miss
their visits for
six months for a year while you get
cleaned up
uh our mom's going has to go to court
that's the only option and that's the
choice he's making yeah not y'all right
yeah no you're right yeah it is so so
hard i'm sorry i'm heartbroken for you
suzanne
yeah
it's a lot it's so yeah it's so much
it's one of the old like not by your
hand but in your lap you didn't ask for
it here it is bamo right
yeah but i keep one and whenever this
gets hard i always want to circle back
to those little kids
yeah and they have somebody
some that an adult has to step in for
them
has to step in for them
the uh
stay on the line here suzanne i'm gonna
give you i'ma send you a copy of this
new book it my new book it's called own
your past change your future and it's
exactly what we're talking about here
you're gonna own this stuff that's hot
what's happened you gotta grieve it and
then you gotta be about doing the hard
gut-wrenching hard stuff of changing
what comes next